what really went on behind closed doors
in the college admissions scandal that
sent felicity huffman and lori lockland
a prison
the fascinating new documentary
operation varsity blues
brings the scam to life with matthew
modine portraying the mastermind
behind it all i can make scores happen
and nobody on the planet can make scores
happen
matthew what was it like taking on a
character like rick singer there was
nothing about this character that i
wanted to bring home and remember
i've created this kind of side door i
don't think rick singer would have
wanted to speak to any
anybody involved in the telling of the
story he's really tight-lipped you know
about everything because he knows
everything he says
can and will be used against him in the
court of law the explosive netflix
documentary uses
fbi wiretap transcripts to recreate
conversations between
singer and parents like lori and
felicity
who paid him to get their kids into
elite schools
what would her chances be without this
process zero she won't get in
zero she has no chance he was fooling
incredibly wealthy people
heads of corporations very bright people
lori and felicity are not portrayed by
actors in operation varsity blues
but lori's personal emails are revealed
and behind closed doors moments like
massimo gianouli confronting a high
school counselor are dramatized
he aggressively asked what i was telling
usc about his daughters
a source tells e.t lori has been
concerned about the documentary
she quote wants nothing more than for
time to pass so people won't be talking
about the college scandal anymore
we're told lori's been offered many
opportunities to open up about what she
has been through
but she can't seem to find the right
words as for felicity
another source tells us her life is back
to normal both her daughters are
thriving in college and she will not be
watching the documentary
director chris smith says getting caught
was always a concern for parents
often they were talking about you know
you know
wanting to make sure that this wouldn't
come out you know so i i don't think
that there was
there was a sense that it was that they
were untouchable at all
you